yes mean is a mathlete Starcraft 2
players meet up for Hans
[Applause]
guys it's gonna be here
my name is Hans Kim and I'm fine as
Jefferson thank you
i watch the mail but my bullies in an
affinity as a [ __ ]
this gender a petition be very
progressive City here I was on the way
over here cell bicyclists with info as
an automobile yeah where's clunky yeah
I think trans people should be allowed
to use whatever bathroom they want to
use thank you but people should because
they make a mess
they don't always clean up after
themselves see suicide Americans I was
at an airport and I saw two you know
book in Arabic which really freaked me
out
but then I saw all the corners of page
with the buck away I was like oh my god
he's a future plans
[Music]
I am Asian you know I am getting fun a
lot in this luscious make fun of Asians
one thing
people say valuations that many dogs
[Music]
[Music]
which is a great shocking to Americans
because an American identity like family
members but in Asia we treat our family
members like family members
this is cultural difference is a mere
thing nation
instead of buying that animal we just
love our grandma
which enable better nation unless you're
a baby girl which case you don't even
remember but everyone else
one of my friends make fun of me because
like to eat General Tso's chicken this
day to cheer for everything
transgender general says my heaven
this video I like teach an Australian in
my Asian friends are like Hans isn't
jealous chicken is a she Americanized
version something authentic vacation
like yeah my favorite movies rush hour 3
I think it's fine that Tanner's white
person's name cover is my next confront
and that's what black men tannest this
is something
I love the Black Panther movies anything
else because they're black children and
he wrote they can finally look up to and
not to someone like Martin Luther King
jr. Malcolm X or Rosa Parks and Harriet
Tubman remaining
with their commercial operation this
George Washington Carver announcement
know
[Applause]
fiancee
[Music]
[Music]
single I get to be my soul mate
maybe it's her polish music Alomar my
friend was like dude you learn at tops
women maybe or maybe women should learn
that was not pointed out right here by
the Federal Reserve this was like she
was like this girl was really into yoga
and choke sex I was like do you drink or
not
[Applause]
[Music]